[موسيقى]
هناك ادوات بديله من الممكن ان يتجه اليها
المتعاملين في الاسواق الماليه او من
لديهم
[موسيقى]
يريدون ان استثمار ادوات امنه تعتبر بديله
اصبح تعطي اعوائد مرتفعه بالمقارنه تعطيه
في السنوات ال14 يعني فقط مستوى تحرك
اسعار الفائده خلال العام 22 من بوينت 2 5
الى 5% يعتبر يعني تحرك خيالي اصبح هناك
من يريد ان يصطاد هذه
الاداه الامن التي تتحقق لم تحققه خلال 14
سنه او 20 سنه
[موسيقى]
اليوم نحن يعني كل الاكتتابات اللي شفناها
خلال الفتره الماضيه كانت تقيم بتقييمات
يقبلها السوق لان السوق كانت مرتفعه
التقييم في ذلك الوقت كانت الارباح كبيره
التي تاتي من من الاكتتابات
بالنسب العليا
ستكون التقييمات اكثر عداله اعتقد اننا
سنتجه الى سوق طروحات اوليه في عداله في
انتقاليه من المستثمرين في مشاركه عادله
في بناء سجل الاوامر وايضا سيكون مدير
الاكتئاب اكثر دقه عندما يضع التقييم
للشركات للمستثمرين المتخرجين او للشركات
التي ستتجه نحو وطرح سنرى مستويات تقييم
مختلفه
[موسيقى]